we should get into the topic of today so
I have a patreon and I allow people to
ask this is what's supposed to be like a
specific video that I could do on like
the regular videos that I do but I
thought this would be a better patreon
podcast topic and I don't know because I
don't know how I would answer this is
such a weird not a weird but a very
difficult question to answer so this is
was asked by Danielle and she is asking
for advice on how to peacefully convince
important figures in your life to be
less racist or homophobic or just at
least getting them to pretend to have
that much human decency would be cool o
of them that's it damn so she cares that
much that she needs to change the mind
of her family members that's tough
that's that's the part where I just
don't know because some people are so
entrenched in their own view
specifically when it comes to stuff like
this like religion and I think the
homophobia has a lot to do with religion
yeah you know yeah one of my uncle's was
like oh we were just talking about how
homosexuality might be something that
you're born with like we're talking
about nature versus nurture and things
like that and I was like oh they were
thinking that the the gene might come
from the mother's side of the family
mmm-hmm and same with baldness and all
this stuff and and it's just a pure
biological talk right yeah it's science
but this guy's so religious he was like
nah he's like are the female side of our
family is very religious so there's not
gonna be any gay people that's type does
that have to do with have to do with DNA
like yeah yeah yeah good one but yeah
because I think cuz you and I know what
we're too Christian to be gay yeah cuz
you and I both grew up been very
religious households yeah and so I even
remember I don't I'm not sure this was a
negative thing but even then as adults
like my parents as adults with their
friends within the church they were
trying to figure out what homosexuality
is they didn't even know what it was
they they couldn't figure out how
somebody could sort of it yes
how they could become gay
so I remember the commerce this is so
weird because it was such a random thing
because my parents used to have stuff at
the house called Kuya gambits and Kuya
members are basically worship that you
do outside of the church and you kind of
do it at somebody else's house oh yeah
it's a great ordeal Bible study clubs
like that yeah so my mom would invite
people over she would create this big
old Korean feast they would you know
whatever eat have fun but they would
worship at the end of the day but I
remember sitting at the table and they
were talking about homosexuality and to
me even as a young person it was a funny
conversation because they were just
saying why are people gay in Korean I
and then somebody said the funniest
[ __ ] thing that I realized as an
adult he goes I think people are gay he
goes it might you might have something
to do with us coming from monkeys but
they were so inquisitive they were
actually try were genuinely trying to
figure out like why are people too gay
yeah because they that's I guess because
if you really look at it from their kind
of perspective yeah just from a
biological standpoint homosexuality
doesn't make sense right because there's
no reproductive goal in it you just you
[ __ ] just if you just you're to find
this the your same-sex attractive and
they couldn't really figure that part
out and they and then you know one
person came in with like that's the
doing of the devil that's the devil
inside your heart you know you suck that
like Christian JK news but for old
people and they were trying to figure it
out and I don't know if um in this
person's case like what what their
severity of or what they define is what
homophobia is right because some people
just can't understand what it is and
they just don't know how to wrap their
head around it so something that either
wasn't explained to them on top of that
or number two maybe they were
reprimanded for even having those
thoughts as a kid yeah they might be gay
and they're hiding it - yeah cuz you
know like some of the most homophobic
people are the most gayest people yeah
they want to be marching in the Pride
Parade do you want to have all kinds of
boyfriends or girlfriends you know but
then they're like
yeah um I I think like in this person's
situation she's probably thinking like
man I hate like being around such
ignorant people and it's frustrating I
can understand that feeling because once
you learn something you you want to help
people that you love and care about to
know it too so they don't come off
looking stupid
but you never change anyone through
anger and frustration like that's
that'll never work and by lecturing
people they'll just shut down even more
also yeah so you don't want to approach
the product you don't want to approach
it as if it's a problem you don't want
to approach it as if like something's
wrong with that something's wrong with
yeah you they need to learn because then
that's very top-down and what I mean by
top-down is like you don't want to come
off as better than anybody no one
listens to that [ __ ] if anyone that
tries to inform other people or lecture
them over the internet or just
face-to-face like no one cares and no
one wants to listen that's the worst way
to teach and try to help people learn
another way that people [ __ ] up is aside
from like what do you call it like like
being so combative about things is like
acting as if people should know already
mmm yeah you know yeah like people don't
know and they're acting racist or
ignorant or homophobic or whatever
because they don't know and you know
they don't know how hurtful it is or
whatever like no one's doing things
maliciously with that intent that's a
very very small percentage of people and
if people like realize that that's how
humans are we'll stop looking at each
other as like bad people or like hateful
people or you know I mean like that's
the that's the first problem is that
you're looking at them as ignorant
hurtful mean hateful stupid whatever
like when you look at people like that
then you can't teach them and you can't
help them learn anything for me I think
a really great perspective flip is hmm
number one if an older generation in my
family they have very negative thoughts
about you know homosexuality or just
kind of like racial superiority type of
stuff and everybody beneath them or
whoever they give birth to their kids
whatever my cousins or whatever don't
agree with them and they've already
moved on that mean
that generation is already gonna die out
yeah they've already they're already
done with their influence and it didn't
affect us so we're fine so I wouldn't
even I would try to flip the perspective
and say that's how they are if you put
your two cents out there and you tried
to convince them in a very nice way and
it didn't work well it's gonna die with
them yeah it is gonna die exactly
because you you already don't think then
and that if that's your parents or your
uncle's or your aunts and they don't
really have an influence on anybody else
and these are just their personal
thoughts then I'm not saying that it's
right or wrong but it's going to die
with them yeah yeah so I wouldn't even
care to even try to change them I think
the best way that people do change is
when they meet the people that they are
racist against or whatever human
connections are usually yeah all this
[ __ ] happens because of tribalism like
you know people that live in Asian
bubbles or white bubbles or whatever and
like they're not meeting face to face
making friends with gay people or
whatever once you do it just changes
your perspective of what you thought you
had you know like especially if you
think that this group is an enemy like
oh this group always steals or this
group always you know wants to control
me or whatever yeah and when you dislike
something so much with a lot of passion
and fervor you will maybe not on purpose
but you will find things that you
dislike about that group way easier than
you would if you just liked them so if
you're looking for it exactly so if you
hate gay people you'll go on Facebook
and you'll find the articles or you'll
find the videos that will bolster that
opinion that gay is bad yeah why gay is
bad right I think politics is a perfect
example oh yeah you're just constantly
looking for all [ __ ] lip tart or yeah
you [ __ ] alright racist or like
you're just constantly looking for that
[ __ ] everybody's cherry-picking data oh
yeah whatever whatever circle you're
looking in whether it's like especially
in Fitness that's a big thing to where
people that are cherry-picking
scientific studies and they'll say oh
this is the reason why this happens or
whatever but a lot of the time too it's
when people are looking for issues as
far as to look for in a different race
they'll look for specific issues or news
stories that are happening
within that race or within that sexual
orientation and they'll make a big deal
out of it so a lot of the times too it's
like you can't really do much from your
point of view but I think what helps is
if you kind of come to the issue with a
little bit of empathy what sounds crazy
to be empathetic with the people that
are racist or sexist or whatever but
there's nothing else you could really do
but kind of change how you react to
those situations unless it's a like for
instance I have a situational personal
story about how my family someone in my
family was a little I guess you could
say homophobic to a certain instance but
over time you know just spending time
with those people or kind of
understanding just like what you said
just being around them and getting to
know them as human beings you don't
really see them yep for that anymore for
being you know gay or straight or
whatever you just kind of carry on but
you have to kind of come from a point of
understanding with these people of how
they grew up yeah and it's not
necessarily their fault it's just their
expectations growing up and there's not
much you could do about it besides just
kind of change how you think about it
yeah I think the the thing that people
[ __ ] up when they try to teach others is
information never helps people like they
think facts and information and data and
like all this [ __ ] you keep spewing out
this stuff people don't learn that way
people learn mainly through experience
and their own self growth so like just
by being in proximity with like let's
say you never hung out with black people
but you're afraid of them because of the
news or whatever like you just think
that they're aggressive or whatever
because you see this on the movies um
and then you know you start hanging out
actually if you start making friends you
start realizing like oh [ __ ] there's
more similarities in the human
experience than differences for all for
everything I find so many more
similarities with people then not one is
all humans are stupid as [ __ ] yeah that
is a huge
similarity and a lot of humans learn
through feeling and experiences and no
one wants to admit that they're wrong so
that's why when you spew information out
at people and you try to change their
mind they never do it never works but
everyone argues all day as if it's gonna
change somebody's mind yeah because you
give people certain just facts that'll
shut down their argument and even before
they even listen to what you're going to
say they have a rebuttal for it yeah so
there nobody's really trying to listen
especially if they're already entrenched
in their own view and they have an
emotional attachment to that hate yeah
whatever you say they're not gonna
[ __ ] listen to it you know it always
starts with being vulnerable and respect
so like if any of us had something to
say all right and then you like I need
to be corrected or whatever there has to
be the rapport first and foremost for
you to be able to give information and
then that person receiving it and going
oh [ __ ] maybe I'm wrong because I trust
David I understand I we have rapport
we're friends I know he has my best
interest in mind so maybe he's
correcting me and I should really take a
look at this that's very different from
from someone who maybe not respect you
and even among friends this happens to
were like some friends are stubborn
because they don't think that you know
more you know better or whatever right
so it takes a very rational and a close
relationship to use information as a way
to teach someone Iran or or it's an
academic environment and you're you're
willing to learn and then you give
information out and then it's like okay
cool so they got to be ready to receive
this information and I think the only
way you can change someone is like it
takes a lot of [ __ ] work like all the
time and work that's why using info and
just spewing out facts is like the worst
thing you could do it's the shortest
thing then it's never gonna work so
you're just gonna fight and you could do
all the right steps to like show
somebody the right way to think mindset
wise but if they're not ready to kind of
accept that or they're not ready to
listen to you or whatever the case may
be they're never going to yea that's why
going back to what David said I think
the main thing is really being okay with
it like use that time to focus on you
and being able to control your emotions
when people say things that you disagree
with and
people do things that make you cringe
that's what I learned over time because
every time I learn some information or
whatever I love to share that with my
friends and I want them to elevate to or
I want them to be informed so they don't
make the same mistakes that I do and
even though I have great intentions I
become too preachy and I become too
annoying and argumented and if people
most people aren't that way you know
like most people don't like to sit there
and argue in debate and learn about
facts and things all day mhm and it gets
tiring so that's like the worst thing
you can do and it does damage to the
friendship and relationship between you
and your family to know these subjects
to are so sensitive I find it really I
find it more the case than not then when
somebody tries to convince somebody not
to be this certain way I usually attack
them they don't they don't come from a
place of like we said before empathy and
you're not really looking to change them
out of the kindness of your heart you're
looking to change them cuz you think
they're a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah and
when you do that people already aren't
going to listen it's like when I when
when my mom and I admit to arguments
[ __ ] it's it clashes a lot because I'm
she probably goes like you know why
you're a [ __ ] idiot it's already off
on the wrong foot
yeah there's there's there's no likely
and it kind of catches people off guard
like what the [ __ ] because if you know
that this is their ideal this is
something that they believe and now
you're attacking one of their beliefs
yeah so if you look at it like that then
you would probably be a little careful
about how you say things yeah you know
this is something that I think all of us
can work on this is something that I'm
learning to work on a lot too because
when something rubs me the wrong way I
try okay you first of all yeah you're
right okay so I know this guy right like
I see he has a lot of potential I'm not
gonna mention who this man is right he's
talking about uborrow I could be very
rude and just be like that's not okay
but let's just start there's specific
cases where this doesn't apply like for
example when